Can you believe that as
a 28-year-old unmarried woman,
I'm literally too old
to be called a spinster?
The correct term for someone
in my apparently geriatric
state is a thornback.
Society is so
obsessed with marriage
that not only do
we define ourselves
by our relationship status,
which was like 42%
of my motivation
for getting my doctorate
in the first place,
but we've created a social ideal
wherein the only way to
truly live happily ever after
is to fall in love
and stay that way.
Yet nearly half of marriages
in the U.S. end in divorce
because love doesn't
always last forever.
I should know, I was
engaged and head over heels
before a bad breakup last year.
Everyone in my life expected me
to be a devastated wreck for
weeks, and I was at first,
but it didn't take long for me
to see the silver linings.
At the time, I was
comforted by a story
about a fellow thornback,
the Hawaiian volcano
goddess Pelehonuamea,
Pele to her friends,
who found love but gained so
much more when it was lost.
It's an interesting story,
even if you haven't recently
had your heart broken,
full of magical fight scenes,
canoes and even murder.
[spooky music]
Maybe you've heard of Pele.
She's a major figure in Hawaiian
mythology and pop culture,
allegedly the inspiration for
Te Fiti in Disney's "Moana"
because Te Fiti is
not a real goddess
in Polynesian folklore.
But most people don't know
that Pele was briefly entangled
with a shape-shifting
demigod named Kamapua'a.
Some would call
him Pele's husband,
but that's not really
an appropriate label
because Hawaiians didn't have
a western concept of marriage.
There were unions
that could be blessed
by gods and the chief,
but they weren't legally binding
and divorce just wasn't a thing.
They don't really teach
us this in history class,
but Hawaii
was a sovereign nation
with its own
language and culture
before colonization
in the 1700s.
They were an oral society
passing their knowledge
about how the world works
onto the next generation
through stories, or mo'olelo.
For example, the
mo'olelo used Kamapua'a
and Pele's relationship
as an explanation
for Hawaii's rich
ecological tapestry.
In myth, Pele is depicted as
the divine embodiment of lava
who is equally likely
to aid or unalive you.
A true chaotic neutral
on the alignment chart,
Hawaiians revered Pele as
the creator of their islands
just as much as they feared
the destruction she caused.
There are many versions
of Pele's story,
but in most of them, Pele
was born to divine parents
in the legendary ancestral
homeland, Kahiki.
Through some linguistic
magic, those Ks become Ts,
and you see the real history
of Polynesian
migration from Tahiti
reflected in Hawaiian mo'olelo.
Pele had many siblings
with their own abilities to
control the sea or clouds,
but she took after
her uncle Lonomakua,
who taught her how
to control fire.
Even as a child, her immense
power, or mana, was obvious.
And not that it matters,
but she was also said
to be quite beautiful.
One of Pele's sisters, a sea
goddess named Namakaokaha'i,
grew jealous and chased
Pele from Kahiki.
In some versions, Namaka
resents Pele's strength,
and in others, Pele has an
affair with Namaka's partner.
Why are you chasing me?
Because you stole my husband.
It wasn't me.
Because you set
my house on fire.
It wasn't me.
Because you're just too strong.
I swear on my life
that it wasn't me!
Gasp!
Okay, maybe it was me.
Pele fled from her sister
with a few of her siblings
trying to find a new home
for them and her fire.
Several times she dug into
the earth to build a fire pit,
only to be flooded by her
sister's salty revenge.
Pele moved southeast from
Kauai to Oahu and then to Maui,
where she ultimately succumbed
to her sister's attack.
But mana as strong as Pele's
can't be stopped by death.
Free from her more human form,
Pele's fiery spirit traveled
to the Big Island of Hawaii
to make her last stand.
Pele's lava made land that
traced the path of her voyage,
and now she lives
with her family
in Hawaii's active
Kilauea Volcano.
Kamapua'a's origins
are just as rocky,
figuratively speaking, since
geology is in his domain.
He is another major figure
in Hawaiian folklore
known as the hog god of Oahu
and associated with
fertility and agriculture.
Again, there are many
versions of the story,
but by most accounts,
Kamapua'a was born on Oahu
to his mother Hina,
the goddess of the moon.
Hina was married
to Chief Olopana,
but was crushing hard
on his more attractive
younger brother.
Born into this
Jon Snow situation
through no fault of his own,
these daddy issues led
Kamapua'a down a violent path.
Like the better
known demigod Maui,
Kamapua'a was a kupua,
a magical shape shifter.
In his human form,
Kamapua'a was handsome and
charming, albeit quick to anger,
but he could shift
at will into a hog
as well as certain
fish and plants.
Heartbroken over his
father's disgust,
Kamapua'a started
raiding Olopana's lands.
In some stories,
he makes his human form more
closely resemble his hog shape
by cutting his hair
short and spiky,
tattooing his body
with dark ink,
and wearing a jacket with
spines down the back.
Kamapua'a was apprehended
and released multiple times
until he was blinded enough
by his fury to kill the chief,
and much like Pele, flee to
the next island in the chain.
He hopped from one
island to another,
picking fights on each one
and earning himself a nasty
reputation as a brute.
Finally, he came to
Hawaii where he saw Pele
and was instantly
enamored of her beauty.
Both Pele and Kamapua'a
had strong personalities.
He was unapologetically
crass and violent,
and she had little
patience to suffer fools,
especially one who was supposed
to be her equal partner.
They were simultaneously too
similar and too different,
clashing in ways that
make great entertainment,
but a terrible relationship.
Kamapua'a stood atop
the volcano crater
where he first saw Pele
and tried to woo her
with songs and dancing,
but Pele, foreshadowing
the rise of Shania Twain,
was not much impressed.
"You're a pig and the son
of a pig!" she derided him,
which sent Kamapua'a
into a fit of rage.
Pele is lovely!
Pele is so sweet!
Pele, you would love me
if only we could meet.
Ew, that's gross.
You're a pig,
and you're the son of a pig!
Yeah? Well, your mother
was a hamster
and your father smells
like elderberries!
Isn't that from "Monty
Python and the Holy Grail"?
We don't even have
elderberries in Hawaii,
and we're about
a thousand years too early
for that reference!
I love that, you know that.
The two hurled
insults at each other
until Pele volleyed with smoke
and flame instead of words.
Kamapua'a easily
countered her attack,
perhaps with weather
powers of his own
or help from his water
god family members.
Pele shook the earth
and sent streams of
lava to burn Kamapua'a,
who turned into grass
to divert her flows
and answered with
floods of his own,
nearly drowning
Pele and her family.
Battle raged until
the two realized
neither one had the upper hand
and their passion transformed
into something more intimate.
For the first time in his life,
Kamapua'a felt loved and happy,
but it wasn't Pele's
responsibility
to keep him that way.
Pele realized that their
relationship was toxic,
though not in the comforting
way that her volcano fumes were
and that it was keeping her
from realizing
her true potential
as Hawaii's eminent
volcano goddess.
She broke up with Kamapua'a
and the two agreed to split
the Big Island in half
so they wouldn't have
to interact again.
I adore this trope
in fiction and myth.
Pele stuck to the western side
where her volcanoes
could generate new earth
and fertilize the existing land.
Kamapua'a took the eastern side,
where his warm rains
could nourish crops.
This juxtaposition in
climate makes the Big Island
one of the most ecologically
diverse places on the planet.
I think the best way to describe
the love these two shared
is fierce, but even
the fiercest affection
can crumble in the face
of incompatibility.
For Pele and Kamapua'a,
their relationship's
achilles heel was anger.
For me and my ex, it was
contrasting views on family
and for millions of
people who break up
or get divorced each year,
the final straw could be
adultery, financial stress,
or a thousand other issues.
Traditionalists
love to talk about
the moral decline of our
society by pointing to marriage,
divorce, and birth rates,
but I think they're missing
the bigger picture here.
Yes, marriage rates
are dropping,
but so are divorce rates.
Younger generations are
waiting longer to get married,
making them more mature
and less likely to fall
into the relationship
pitfalls their parents did.
And the older generations
who are experiencing slightly
higher divorce rates,
mostly initiated by
women, by the way,
are ending incompatible
relationships
that likely shouldn't
have been legally bound
in the first place.
And if our society
didn't pressure people
to get married so
young for so long,
maybe they wouldn't have.
Is it a coincidence that Hawaii,
a culture that historically
didn't have the
concept of marriage,
has the lowest divorce
rate in the U.S.?
I don't think so.
These divorcees are
learning a powerful lesson.
Breakups are good actually.
If a relationship isn't
working, it's better to end it
and be grateful
for the benefits.
After Pele left him, Kamapua'a
fled to a distant island
and married a chieftess,
supposedly getting his
own happily ever after.
Pele got to realize her dream
of basking in her own glory
and living with her
fire and family.
And when my engagement ended,
I was able to focus
on my friendships
and eat Nutella again.
I'm glad mythology is
full of love stories
and tragedies alike,
but I wish there were more
stories like this one,
where losing love
wasn't seen as tragic.
So at the next
all-millennial meeting
when we decide which
industry we're going to ruin,
I'm doubling down on marriage.
Not because I don't
believe in love; I do,
but because all of Polynesia
would've been worse off
if Pele and Kamapua'a had
actually been married.
You can choose to ignore
this mythical precedent
if you wish, but I
have learned my lesson.
I still want to fall in love
and have a big party though.
It's time for another
fantasy pantheon pick,
and it is my turn to
choose a new pick.
Are you ready, Dr. Z?
-Yes, I'm excited.
-Okay.
My pick from the Hawaiian
pantheon is Laka.
-Oh.
-Have you heard of her?
Is she the one that's
most associated with hula?
-Yes!
-Yay!
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Okay.
She's the goddess of the hula.
And so she is
a goddess of dance,
which I think we will
absolutely want in our utopia.
Of course.
But she's also a goddess
of forest growth and love,
and I think that
all of that energy
is something we want
in our perfect world.
Those are three
things I really love,
so I appreciate that pick.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.